[Applause]
our next guest is an oscar-nominated
actress who might be best known for
taking all your money at the poker table
and her role in the child's play
franchise the latest installment is a
series called Chucky you can see an all
new episode tonight on sci-fi and USA
but she was also part of this scary and
possibly very costly scene in her
bathroom no oh no
oh
oh no I made
a big mistake
[Applause]
by America
dream back uh say hello to Jennifer
Tilly everybody
hello Hi how are you I'm so good I mean
I I said scary scene but that bath kind
of looked magical well what's the story
did you forget it was on every single
season when there's only been two
seasons so far myself and dumbass he
knew the creator of the Chucky series we
like to take a naked bath together for
social media and you know and Don is
conveniently gay so he's not interested
in me in that way conveniently gay
that's amazing okay so this was this
season I was like oh I wanted to make
sure that I had a lot of bubbles to
cover my it's and bits because I have
more its and bits than usual nobody
wants to see them so I put a whole jug
of bubble bath in the bathtub and then I
turned on the jacuzzi and I went out of
the room just for a second and then I
came back and obviously it did the trick
but the good thing is there were lots of
bubbles more than enough bubbles
it kind of looks amazing yes and you
know what everybody's jealous because
Dawn and I do our little naked bathtub
scene and they don't want to be in it
but I think if you have other people in
the bathtub scene it becomes salacious
and you have like the straightness
it becomes like a weird sexual
harassment thing like yeah Jennifer
Tilly made us take naked bath with her
yes human resources
yes favorite part of today is
conveniently gay
um so so wait have you ever had a
bathtub like a bath get away from you
and forget like with your kids like you
left it on
my kids just my kids just push the water
out oh yeah they don't they don't need
it to go over they just push it over and
just splash and try to dive and stuff
it's like awkward I mean they're playing
yeah they think it's it's like the ocean
and it's weird yeah kids love bathtubs
yeah I do too my boyfriend wants okay
I'm not gonna say he smokes pot because
um I'm not gonna say that but he gets
but he's absolutely
he turned on the bathtub and he forgot
about it and he wandered away and he
went his um office doing like you know
the kinds of things that seem very very
very important when you're in that sort
of floaty state of mind and then he
heard a noise he's like what is that
noise and it was like glub Club glub and
he looked and there was all this water
pouring under oh under the door of his
office and then he was like oh no oh no
he went in there was about a foot of
water all over the apartment and it
turned out that a lot of the other
apartments down below they had major
water damage and Phil paid for it all it
was like over seventy thousand dollars
he paid for it in his poker money which
came out of his boxing comes in big
bricks it's not like real money it's
like here have a couple bricks of money
please please don't sue us I just want
to come over to your house yes
you seem like so much fun yeah like and
soda still yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign